so that wasn't easy but that was the
warm-up to the real question which is
part three so we're both gonna have to
think about this let M be the midpoint
of the chord PQ by considering the
quadrilateral it's not too bad
p ql k or otherwise show that m k equals
m l all right so there's a lot there the
quadrilateral PQ l PQ okay I haven't got
on my diagram so I'm going to draw it
right now okay
PQ is there LK is there so now I'm just
gonna try to emphasize that okay now
this question by the way I now know this
is a right angle so I'm gonna go ahead
I'm gonna solidify that this question
part three is all about vision what as
soon as you see it yeah it's obvious the
algebra just kind of falls out right now
we therefore need to stare really hard
and that's why I'm going to so much
effort to like make this diagram a good
diagram when we think about PQ LK what
kind of a quadrilateral is it hmm now I
can see from part one and two all I've
really established is these two right
angles that's really all I've done okay
and it doesn't really look like it's not
it's not a rectangle not a square not a
parallelogram but you've got these guys
and you need to think really hard we've
learnt about you learn about all this
all the kinds of quadrilaterals you need
to know about basically in u7 but in
this most recently you've learned about
another kind of quadrilateral that's
different which you can't learn about
back then and it has to do with these
two angles in here when you've got those
two right angles and it's in a
quadrilateral
what kind of quadrilateral would be
hmmm this is a cyclic quadrilateral now
think about this
it's cyclic but how can I actually prove
that because they say show right we're
considering the quadrilateral we've
worked out yes it is cyclic but how
would I prove that it is the case what
is it about like these guys that makes
it cyclic you think for a second can I
rub this off what you want to yeah John
take a picture yes okay it's not that
hard this time what's the definition of
a cyclic quadrilateral it's the
definition very good if you have a
cyclic quadrilateral all points all
corners vertices is the technical word
but anyway all corners are on the
circumference of a circle now if that is
true then I should be able to draw a
circle it's gonna be a bad circle but
I'm gonna do my best shot right I should
be out of draw a circle that goes all
the way through so I'm just gonna
imagine I think it'll look something
like this okay there you go it's pretty
horrendous circle but it's good enough
okay now what property am I going to use
that shows that this is a quite a cyclic
quadrilateral now there are a couple of
main properties of cyclic quads that I
know the opposite angles in a cyclic
quite on what opposite angles there so
for example if I have this one like this
right this angle this angle right very
clearly not equal are they right and I
could make it like fatter up here and
they would not be equal but that's still
cyclic so what's the relationship
between them they add up to 180 degrees
so they're supplementary now that's like
the main quality we use that cyclic
quads but I can't use that directly here
because I don't know what any of the
angles in the corners are right I don't
know that angle I know some of this
anger
but not the whole thing so these angles
are not angles of the cyclic
quadrilateral there it goes in the
cyclic quadrilateral so how else can I
use it have a look at the have a look at
that big circle that I'm trying to draw
on the outside right when you look at
these two right angles what do they make
you think of in this circle they're
triangles there right I'm going to track
for what a little forked further look
back at the question they tell us that M
K equals M L where r MK and ml yep
there's Mk
there's ml right now have a look K and L
are on the circumference of the circle
so what are these lines in this circle
they they must be radii do you see that
like I don't know I haven't proved that
they are but but they must be right like
how else am I going to do this so if
they are radii and M is the middle of
this chord here that makes PQ a special
chord what kind of chord is it it's it's
it's a diameter right that that's why M
which is the center of it is the center
of the whole circle okay so let me try
and tie all of these um threads together
I guess this is part three I'm going to
say P L Q which is what I was looking at
the previous part it's equal to p KQ
like so okay but that means that K and L
are on the circumference and P and Q are
in the circumference of a circle because
do you see that they are angles standing
on the same arc anak PQ right so since
this is true I can say P Q K and L do
you remember the word there's a word
that starts with vamsi that means
they're all in the same circle
some con cyclic the reason why they're
cancelling is because of this the angles
standing on arc what's it called what's
this arc PQ right you see it upside down
on arc PQ are equal okay so that tells
me okay it's a cyclic quad right do you
see it now but if it's a cyclic quad and
if you have a look at say arm plq right
that's not just any angle in this circle
it's an angle that's 90 degrees in a in
a circle what angle is 90 degrees angle
you know what is 90 degrees you actually
said it before it was to do with this
slime being a special line this is a
diameter right so we call this guy this
guy see how that's a semicircle 217 so
we call it the angle in a semicircle
what does that ring a bell right so I
can say but angle p lq is 90 degrees
therefore angle p or q is the angle in a
semicircle cause it's 90 degrees right
if you draw a 90 degree angle in a
circle anywhere you find the diameter
we're used to do it the other way around
we're used to saying hey here's a
diameter now find an angle any one you
like but if you had a random circle
right and just just make a 90 degree
angle anywhere just put like a random
line over here and then and then go 90
degrees like that you have found the
diameter right so many properties in
circles they go both ways
okay so therefore P or Q is the angle in
a semicircle right but that means that P
Q is the damodar
if PQ is the diameter M which is the
center that ionna
is the center of the entire circle
because the center of any diameter is
the center of the circle okay M is the
center I've already shown that K and L
are on the circumference therefore this
is the last line M K and M L must both
be equal because they are radio okay so
oh my brain what makes this question
hard quite a few things for starters the
this is actually and this is what the
HSC does this is what makes HSA
questions so hard this is not is
actually not just a parametric question
it is clearly multiple topics right
you've got the Pat matrix in there in
part one and two and then in part three
just have a look at my working
there's no parametric's here it's
completely circle geometry and not only
is it circle geometry it's hard circle
geometry right we're used to being given
diameters and finding the angles but
we're now asking you to go and reverse